[Music]
let's go to ann in
wolves kentucky what's up ann
hi dr john how are you today remarkable
and you
oh i'm great here in louisville
louisville louisville louisville
what's up how are you not much so um
i just wanted to call uh thanks for
chatting with me today but right now um
i'm just struggling with managing my
work life balance and my family life
i'm finding a lot of value in the work i
do and the hours i spend at work but i
feel like i'm jeopardizing a lot of my
family life because i focus so much on
work
i'm speaking your guidance i guess on
how i redirect this and how i find
balance
i think balance is a myth what do you
think when you think of balance i don't
think it's real i think it's a and it's
a it's a fantasy it's not real
but people have a picture in their head
of what it's supposed to look like what
does your picture look like
so in that perfect world i think would
be 50 50 but we're finding you know as
you go day by day that's certainly not
possible or it doesn't feel possible
realistically when you're actually doing
it
um
but it would be great if i could you
know
split my time 50 50 or even 60 family 40
work life balance but
right now in the past i'm i'm taking it
just doesn't feel like that's doable
so
something has kept you from
pulling the trigger either way what is
it
you know i think really right now what
it is i'm just
i struggle with my self-worth and i
think i find a lot of myself worth in
the amount of work i do
not so much
in the quality of work i do and i think
that's just honesty when we get down you
know to the core of it i think
it's how much can i do today it's not
you know stepping away and
you know promoting that healthy
work-life balance it's just
how much can i do i almost get manic
about it i think it's the best way to
describe it where does that come from
gosh i think so
when i was younger i was at 11 i was
diagnosed with anorexia and so
i always kind of correlate it with that
i guess it's uh i have to find
um
i don't know i have to focus on
something to not focus on that like i
have to
really
concentrate on something hard to kind of
get those negative feelings out of my
head if that makes sense the negative
you mean the the anorexic demons calling
you or just the sense that you're not
enough you don't look right you don't
play right you're not a good enough this
you're not good enough of that
i think at a deeper level it's probably
i'm not a good enough whatever it is
that day so
sometimes that comes out in food um
sometimes that comes at my relationship
with my child
and my husband
um
but a lot of times it comes out you know
in my relationships at work and
you know
in the work i do
i'm a property manager so i mean it's
600 units so it's every day it's
something but it's
i've been you know even told by my
supervisors you need to learn when to
turn it off but it's like i don't have
that off switch
so tell me if this sounds right and also
tell me if i'm wrong okay i've been told
i'm wrong several times on the show by
kelly and james so feel free to hop in
um
how much of it is you can control things
at work you're good at what you do you
know how to solve problems and that is a
hurricane that you can grab the tale of
and control it
and when you look in the eyes of your
little kid
and you look in the eyes of your husband
there's a recklessness and a strength to
that love that is uncontrollable
and it feels out of your grasp
and it's simply safer for your heart and
your body and your soul to go back to
work because i know the rules there and
i know a plus b equals c
because love is a risk
and i can't control that risk does that
sound right or my way off
no that that's exactly right i think
that's absolutely correct i think it's
you know when i'm at work
it's it's
i don't want to say it's easy but it it
just makes sense and it's easy to
control certain situations
and then at home it's like
hostile sometimes and it's
high emotions and it's high stress and
not that work isn't but
so where does that stress at home come
from do you bring it home or is your
husband a jerk or you just have a
two-month-old that's just bananas like
where's it come from
i think my husband and i
we both work very high-demand jobs we
both he's in school full-time
you know i work 60 70 hours a week on a
good week um and then we come home and
we we bring all of that high anxiety
home
and that's what our three-year-old thing
of course so then i wonder how it's
affecting him long term he's three
he's three and he's so he's always
seeing these two super stressed out
parents yeah so what i would tell you is
he's not seeing it
there's actually some research dr gabor
mate is
he is absorbing that at the genetic
level
yeah it's becoming part of him
how mommy and dad talk to one another
how they interact with one another how
they are courtesy and serve one another
how they love one another how they touch
each other how they look and laugh
he's absorbing that
and it has epigenetic um consequences
both up and down
he's not just watching it he's absorbing
it
um
so
christy again my friend christopher and
stay on the line here um kelly's gonna
send you a copy of her brand new book
take back your time it's on this exact
topic
um
she does a great job of
this idea of seasons versus balance
balance is bullcrap it's not real and
it's a myth sold to you by
every
the name of the game in selling is
i have to convince you that you're
missing a thing so that i you'll buy my
thing right
and
if there's this myth of balance life
never feels 50 50.
and so we just pathologically add stuff
to either side of that scale trying to
get it to balance up and then just as
always stays wonky so i'm gonna buy a
new
i'm gonna sign up for a yoga class but
that takes time so then i'm going to
get a bunch of new fancy pots and pans
because we're going to cook together and
that doesn't work so then i'm going to
you know i mean you're always just
teeter-tottering on this thing
and
instead of looking at it 50 50 balance
look at the season so your husband's
working a demanding job and he's in
school full-time is that right yes yes
and you have a three-year-old
yes
so and you're working 70 hours a week in
a job that you're really good at
probably weren't put on earth to be a
property manager maybe you were um but
you're kicking butt in it and they say
hey way to go but even your boss is like
how about we take 30 off how do we dial
it back a little bit and you're like
never
never exactly
so
um the conversation and she's got some
stuff in her book that's great that um
you can work through with your husband
but
it's just taking a breath and saying
okay we're in a season right now
like i'm in that same season too it's
the fall i'm on the road a lot i'm
speaking my wife's got a book coming out
she's working on retreats and all kind
of stuff she's also a professor she's
getting flown to another state to teach
because she's so good at it
it's
bananas in our house and i got a sixth
grader and a kindergartner
and so we're in a season and we
over-committed and most of it's my fault
but we over-committed and so we're
saying okay what's it gonna look like
till december this isn't this fake 50-50
because that's not real
what's it gonna look like to get through
christmas and then what's our spring
gonna look like because that's what we
can control we've already signed up for
stuff this fall
and so y'all are in a bonkers season
what is life gonna look like where can
we extract joy out of the season that
we're in
and what i want you all to do is come up
with a a map for what this season's
gonna look like and then the spring will
look like and here's gonna be your
adventure right now
your adventure is when you get home and
you start to feel that
whatever take off in your body i want
you to be really intentional about
writing down where it is
do you feel your chest start to get
tight do you feel your stomach drop do
you feel your necks start to get start
to hurt i want you to begin to feel it
in your body and now be mad at yourself
and don't judge yourself i can't believe
this i
i want you to start being really curious
with anne
like what's my body trying to protect me
from right now
what am i missing here is it sleep is it
connection with my with my kid and i
know getting on all fours and playing is
so fun but it's so boring
but what am i missing here
when's the last time my husband had sex
that was great it wasn't just this duty
checklist thing that we found actual
like
joy we were like really into one another
for more than one night maybe it's two
or four so what what when's the last
time we were intimately connected for a
season right i want you to begin to have
those conversations together and with
yourself start to experience where this
stuff is in your body
do you think you and in fact i was just
reading a meta-analysis on eating
disorders the other day and the
prognosis that what they don't know
is just mind-boggling to me
um did you
did you heal from childhood stuff or are
you still playing are you still running
um
i think i'm still running you know i
i do um i just got out of a really bad i
guess we could say i i got over a really
bad relapse i don't think you ever get
over it but i thought
you know
it started to creep its
head back in right around the time and
turned two okay
um
what was going on in your world
was intimacy at an all-time low was
husband gone were you stressed at work
what was going on at home
i
i think
at home our life was completely chaotic
my husband and i were fighting all the
time
um we had fundamental disagreements
regarding money and regarding how we
wanted to run our household
we just purchased a home which naturally
brings stress into the equation
um
and
you know we're trying to deal with both
both sides of our emotions
and raising a three-year-old and i think
you know with covet and everything going
on there was no physical escape my
physical escape became work you know
what was left of it during that time and
um so it almost felt like you had for me
i had no control over anything in my
household like i didn't have control
over my relationship with my husband it
was so toxic at that time and we've been
in therapy and we've
you know and that's been great we're
doing much better now but everything
just seemed very chaotic in our lives
and you could control that right
yes that's part of the challenge is
figuring out how to do that because
there was a point i think during all of
that that we that we didn't feel we
could but
um
no i'm saying i'm saying your body began
to say oh i remember i remember
something i can control
yes um and it's so
it's not funny but it's ironic because
when you try to explain eating disorders
to people who don't understand such as
my husband who's never been around it
i'm like
you know it's totally unconscious
unconscious like i don't i don't think
about it i just fall back into these
habits and then one day things calm down
and
i think about it again and i'm like okay
i am falling back down that down that
rabbit hole and you kind of have to pull
yourself back up because
you don't even realize you're losing the
control when you are yeah and it can be
yeah it can be disassociative that's
right so a couple things one i'm gonna
send you that book okay i don't want you
to ever say work life balance ever again
as long as you live
okay i want you to start thinking in
seasons and sometimes in the winter it's
just really cold you gotta wear jackets
you don't go outside so much
and or you gotta go outside and you know
it's gonna be cold out there and then
sometimes it's summer and it's really
hot
but you go to the pool
and you dress differently and same in
the spring and same in the fall
life rolls in seasons not in balance
we've been sold a lie it's not real
and so i want to give you this book i
want you to read it closely and it's
brand new it's just number one
bestseller just came out the other day
um it's incredible and christy is a
great friend
i i want you to do the exercise in that
book you and your husband and counseling
i want you to be highly intentional
about telling your counselor i'm
struggling with this and i'm ready for
the first time
in years
to set this down and you're right the
the quote-unquote ever be done with it
um
i both understand the data and the data
like the research is clear
it's hard to say i'm ever over
um anorexia that's tough
and i also believe
deeply in people setting these bricks
down in healing and it just doesn't come
back anymore
and that's highly intentional getting
connected with your body and what your
body's trying to tell you on a regular
basis it sounds like what your body's
telling you right now and has been for a
while
that your most important relationships
are not whole right now with your
husband
with your kid
and you are in fight or flight and
probably have been for years
and you are running to work because you
can control that
you are
disassociating yourself you're
distancing yourselves a better word from
the relationships because those hurt
and they're not solid right now
and it may be that he's got time for him
to step away from school for a season
for the sake of his marriage and his
family
it may mean that he can't work full-time
and y'all got to make some pretty
serious financial sacrifices and he's
going to go to school full-time and
you're going to make this for a season
until he gets out of school and then
he's going to go back to the workforce
full-time
it may mean that you step back
and say i'm going to lock eyes with this
three-year-old and this three-year-old's
gonna be my world or maybe your husband
quits everything and he locks eyes with
this three-year-old whatever that looks
like the pace y'all are on is
unsustainable
and you know that
your kid feels that and your husband
knows it and now it's this weird dance
this weird game of chicken and which
one's gonna cave first and if one of you
loses you both lose
and so the conversation has got to be
leveled up here um and you've got to be
highly intentional about what
this season's going to look like being
intentional and direct about planning
for next season and something's going to
have to give in the next season
somebody's going gonna have to give in
the next season
and i'm convinced if you get serious
about not to say you haven't been
serious if you get highly intentional
and submit and vulnerable
to healing from anorexia i'm convinced
you can i know you can
you're too strong
you're too
brilliant i know you can i know no no
you can
and it's time now it's been exhausting
in his time
thank you so much for this call and stay
on the line here and um
we'll um we'll get you that book sent
out
never everybody never say the word
work-life balance not real it's a season
it's a season
life goes in rhythms and in seasons
identify the season you're in some
seasons are sprint seasons like our
first caller trying to get paid get get
out of debt
some seasons are we build trust we build
trust like the second caller build trust
we build trust we build trust
and then
man we gotta have a season of winter we
got some hard accountability with our 15
year old we're gonna have to really
change how we parent how we interact
it's gonna be hard
and then there will be other seasons of
spring the sun will come up again the
flowers will bloom um we'll have a
difference we'll have a different season
but knowing where you're at not trying
to balance it all balance and i'll
balance it all and we love you man we're
standing behind you call me every step
of the way if we can help okay time to
get serious about your marriage time to
get serious about parenting serious
about healing your heart